this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists dear listener have
you ever thought about getting rid of
everything you
ever owned well maybe not everything but
in more ways than one minimalism is
really about starting over
with less now that can be a blank canvas
a blank slate
sure sort of like what we did with this
new studio space we're in
which by the way if you're watching this
on youtube you'll notice these backdrops
we're building out this beautiful new
studio we've already done three studio
tours over at
patreon.com the minimalist if you want
to check those out
we started out with a blank slate you in
fact you hear it a lot with
well with meditating in particular i
remember when you and i were doing the
waking up
app together we brought sam harris in
here and talked to him about it one of
the things he always says is
now it's time to begin again yeah and
that is so useful not just in meditation
but
if i'm having a conversation if uh you
know i'm having uh i don't know
if i'm having trouble in the moment yes
with whatever it is
i can tell myself all right all right
begin again yes yeah
i i think it's interesting because a lot
of the questions i saw today
people are asking about uh well maybe
not a lot of them but a few of them
about starting over with nothing why
would i want to get rid of all my stuff
and start over
but there are so many different ways to
start over it doesn't necessarily mean
creating an empty life or creating a
white canvas and starting over fresh
you know totally new right you can do
that and
if you want to do that great sometimes
that's perfectly appropriate
and it's preferable even right yeah sure
and that's one way of starting over
exactly there's so many different ways
to start i'm thinking of you know we're
always starting over sometimes there are
sort of mile markers to
mark the occasion and opportunities for
us to start over or even
sort of the warning signs that man i
feel like i really
want to start over i want to begin again
for me the obvious two that sort of
happened back to back the one-two
gut face punch that i had was my mom
died my marriage ended both in the same
month back in 2009
and that was sort of the press the
precipice for us for the whole
minimalism thing for me to start
simplifying my life realizing like oh i
want to start over
pretty soon after that i left the
corporate world and then you were laid
off from the corporate world
that was an opportunity to start over
yeah it was starting over with my stuff
but it was also starting over
financially i got rid of my car payment
i got rid of my mortgage
um so yeah i look forward to uh yeah
just diving into these questions and
really
talking about these different ways to
start over but you know one thing i'll
say
uh that does apply to all of it is that
i love how you talked about minimalism
being this tool to help you start over
i've never really looked at it that way
but i think about less is now
right our documentary on netflix and
that is about
starting over it's about starting new
right and yeah if someone is looking to
start anew they can use minimalism to
help them do that
and minimalism is not about starting
over with nothing it you can get down to
nothing
it's about identifying what is
appropriate and starting over
with less now a few other times in our
lives
that really stand out to me if you're
leaving a job
obviously or maybe you're just moving to
a new workplace
maybe you're where you worked before is
moving buildings even that's an
opportunity to start over or you just
move into a new office in the same
building you're starting
over or maybe you're 17 years old and
you're jehovah's witness father kicks
you out of the house and you have to
start over
hypothetically hypothetically speaking
yeah yeah or maybe move to a new
city or a new home or a new apartment
that is an opportunity to start over
in fact anything can be an opportunity
to start over it's a brand new
day it's an opportunity to start over
yeah you know during the minimal episode
today that's what we're going to talk
about we're going to talk about starting
over we're going to answer your
questions
on the maximal episode over on patreon
patreon.com
the minimalist we're going to talk about
40 life lessons
from 40 years since i'm turning 40
next week which by the way is another
opportunity to start over
you don't have to wait until one of
these big milestone birthdays or
anniversaries
it can just be october 13th and you
decide
that's the day i want to start over or
maybe it's february 5th
that's the day i want to start over
whenever it is
it's an opportunity to start over but i
am turning 40 we're gonna do an episode
next week about
birthday gifts but this uh thursday on
patreon
we're gonna do 40 life lessons from 40
years 40 things i've learned and we're
going to answer a bunch of
your questions as well ryan let's dive
into some of these questions here we
have one from
twitter lauren has a question for us as
i'm
letting everything go and starting over
how do i explain it to my friends and
family who think i am crazy
or terminally ill it reminds me when we
were in the corporate world and people
were asking me if you were suicidal
because i was getting rid of stuff right
i'm like weird yeah i'm like he's
depressed
but not suicidal
and the the thing is with the stuff
that is often a indicator that someone
is either going to kill themselves
or it's an indicator that i
finally have identified what my true
priorities are
it has nothing to do with all of this
access stuff
that's getting in the way of living a
more meaningful life lauren let me say
this
who told you that you have to explain
yourself that's exactly what i was
thinking about
you know it's funny because she's
telling herself she has to explain
and your society is also telling you and
maybe even the people around you are
saying
hey lauren i need you to explain this to
me now that they may not say that
explicitly although someone might but
they are saying it in the way that they
talk to you
the way that they judge you and now a
lot of that though a lot of that
pressure you feel a lot of those
expectations you feel
they are internal and so most people
don't really care
about the explanation now if someone
does come to you and they are truly
concerned
for you then certainly if you feel
compelled to
not by society but you feel compelled
because
of your loving bond with this other
person
then great maybe it's an opportunity
when ryan came to me and he was like
hey man why the hell are you so happy
but that was an opportunity for me
to not convince him of anything but to
just simply say oh
here's something that's really helping
me and it might help you as well because
what you're suffering from some of the
same miseries from which i was suffering
at the time
yeah so lauren you might be uh you know
the subject of some judgment right now
but remember judgment is but the mirror
reflecting
the uh the traits of the person who's
doing the judging i know i paraphrased
and butchered that quote but
yeah it's all the insecurities it really
is yeah it's the insecurities that
they're projecting onto you
so you got to think that that is a it's
a temporary
judgment that's happening really what
your friends and family want excuse me
what your friends and family want
they want you to be happy they want you
to be content
they want you to live a meaningful life
they want you to be consistent
and if you can show your friends and
family through consistency
that that this simplifying of your life
is making you happy it's making you
content
eventually they're going to support you
but that initial judgment
that initial thing that you think you
need to explain away there
actually isn't a way to explain it away
the only way you can really
convince others that you're doing what's
right for you is by
living a a deliberate uh a deliberate
meaningful life being consistent with it
that is what they're looking out for
yeah and i think that when you're
talking about your friends
you know what they may want all those
things that ryan just said maybe they do
want you to be happy they want you
to live a meaningful life but maybe they
don't and that's okay too
if they yeah it doesn't matter what your
friends want is what i'm saying if they
want those things
that's wonderful right whatever they
want
has no bearing on the life that you want
to live their expectations and even
their standards their beliefs their
opinions their preferences are not
yours and you don't have to adopt them
if you find some best practices from
them that you
will find value in yourself wonderful
but it's not your obligation
to take on their expectations yeah we
have a question here from ashley in
chicago illinois
it's been about four months and i'm
still job searching
and haven't came across anything i
haven't been applying to the same field
that i was previously in
because i didn't enjoy it but the
pressures and stress of not having a job
is getting to me and i feel like i
should just bite the bullet
and try to find another job in that same
field
until i read a blog on your website
saying that being laid off was the
greatest thing that happened to you
so ultimately my question was what were
your
next steps that you took after being
laid off
and did you have any fears when you were
going through this process
and if you did how did you handle them
because i'm definitely
feeling it actually uh i i totally
relate with that fear because when i
first got laid off
i mean i did do everything i could to
pay off as much debt as possible
to uh get rid of my car payment get rid
of my mortgage i did as much as i could
to save some money to give myself some
time to really figure it out
uh but ultimately you know there was a
certain point where
i was thinking to myself you know what
maybe i'm going to have to go get
a job just to sustain sustain myself and
pay the bills
and there was no shame in that i mean
ultimately i could have went have been a
barista i mean we talk about that often
one day
josh that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna be baristas eventually
but really um i even took on a job
because i you know i was in sales i took
on a job
selling uh uh decomposable plastics
right i remember that for a company so
that wasn't my dream job that certainly
is what i wanted to do the rest of my
life but
yeah if you're feeling the pressure of
having to pay the bills
then you might have to go cut grass i
mean i'm just throwing something out
there actually i'm not literally telling
you to go cut grass
but you know you might have to do a job
that is just a job in the meantime and
there's no shame in doing that
there are two sides to the equation
right it's it's the amount of money you
make and it's the amount of money you
spend and of course
you can get your expenses down as low as
close to zero as possible that's what
you and i both did i moved to a much
smaller apartment yeah
uh when i left the corporate world back
in 2010 2011. oh wow
2011 is when we both left the corporate
world and and so i remember
when i walked away from that i had paid
off the vast majority of my debt i sold
my house i
sold cars i i paid off my
the car the last car i had left and no
credit card debt got out of all the debt
that i could
reduced all of my expenses i didn't even
have home internet
home cable any of these things because
they weren't
necessities for me right let me tell you
what a necessity was for me
at the time and it still is today but at
the time i realized what was absolute
absolutely essential to me was my
freedom
and i'll tell you this freedom is
actually
terrifying as well yeah because we think
of freedom as one thing
it's doing whatever you want whenever
you want that's not
real freedom real freedom involves some
sort of self-restraint
right because if you can do whatever you
want whenever you want that's hedonism
that's not really what we're talking
about
here that's that's a different thing and
and so
i didn't simply walk away from the
corporate world and do whatever i want
whenever i want
but i sort of did in the sense that once
i understood
the level of self-restraint that was
required and not spending
excess money then i was able to identify
what my
absolute basic needs were what do i
truly need what is essential
to live the life that i want to live i'm
it may even feel like i'm depriving
myself temporarily
it's almost like a withdrawal from
consumer purchases right
yeah in fact that entire year one of the
ways that i started over in 2011
i needed something to write about on the
website so i said hey you know i'm gonna
have a new year's resolution i'm not
gonna buy anything new for a year
and i failed at that but it was a wild
success in a different way it was an
awesome lesson
exactly not just for you but for for
many people um
man i uh oh i totally lost i thought i
was gonna say
that's right let me keep going here so
when i'm talking to
to ashley here about the stress and the
fear
yes there was a lot of stress in the job
that i was in
yeah but just because you you leave that
doesn't mean all of a sudden it's going
to be your life is going to be
stress-free in fact there will be
different stressors no matter what we do
there's going to be some sort of stress
in our life
and sometimes we look at that as good
stress or bad stress our body doesn't
differentiate
between the two right by the way stress
yeah it's stress or stress
yes indeed and so when i when i think
about that i also think about the fear
and i knew for me the there was actually
a different kind of fear
it was i was more afraid to stay
than i was to go in that scenario so
starting over for me
became easier it certainly became
simpler when i identified that
fear of staying i looked out 5
10 20 years if i kept down this path
i told myself i'd be different from you
know the bosses that i worked for
or the other corporate executives in the
company but the truth is
i wasn't going to be considerably
different i was headed down the same
exact path i was going to end up
in a similar or the same destination and
that was
more terrifying than the
fear of the unknown and really that's
what ashley is talking about here is
the fear of the unknown well how do i
deal with the fear of the unknown i ask
myself a couple questions
what is the worst thing that could
happen okay that's an obvious one
but i always couple that with what is
the best thing
that could happen because we always move
toward that catastrophic thinking
and it's okay to try to understand okay
what is the worst thing that's going to
happen here
because it's probably not as bad as i
actually think it's going to be but
what is the upside of me making this
decision as well absolutely
you know when you approach things that
way
you usually end up falling somewhere in
the middle you know maybe not right in
the middle but
but pretty close to the middle i
remember what i was going to say
when josh and i left our jobs we did get
like you know a little bit of severance
but you know we had with that severance
was like six
maybe seven months worth of bills it
wasn't um
it wasn't like we had people assume
because i've had this on twitter a lot
we're like oh it's easy for guys who had
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars saved up
god no yeah so um i bring that up
because
yes it's important to have a savings
josh and i often talk about having that
that six month emergency fund
that is but that's why that emergency
fund is so important it's because when
you're in a position
like ashley is you have some time to
kind of figure things out now she's been
at it for four months
um again ashley it might be time to find
a job to pay the bills but that doesn't
mean you're giving up
that just means you are surviving you're
paying for the bills that you need to
pay for
and still while you are you know making
that that earning however it is
uh it's it's it's totally possible to
start looking for something
that is more appropriate for your life
that you want to do and what direction
are you
headed in so when we're talking about
starting over that's really what we're
talking about is
we're identifying a new direction and
it's generally it can be
but it's generally not a 180 degree
shift for some people it's a 5 or 10
degree shift in a different direction
and you're like oh that but that's not
that difficult no it's not
but a year from now five years from now
10 years from now a five degree shift
puts you in a radically different
location
than if you were to stay on the same
path if you weren't
to start over you were just to stay on
the same path you're going to end up in
a place where
you may not want to be but a slight
shift
can take you where you want to go
absolutely so ashley i'm going to send
you a copy of
ryan's in my last book we wrote a book
called everything that remains and
it is the story of the two of us leaving
the corporate world to suit and tie
corporate guys
and sort of jettisoning their stuff but
also
leaving behind that lifestyle of
clinging and status and trophies and
so-called success
and achievement for a different life a
life that was more
appropriate for us it's called
everything that remains if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of that or
actually if you want the book book or
the ebook version of that
we'll be happy to send that to you as
well sean if you can reach out to ashley
and send her a copy of everything that
remains i'd appreciate it
we have a question from ally on facebook
when you're starting over from scratch
and you realize you can't do it alone
how do you get over your pride and ask
others for help so here's the thing
uh i i would i don't know i want to hear
what you have to say about this because
i think you and i might have a different
perspective yeah
maybe um well
i mean do i need anyone no but
it certainly makes things a lot
more i want to say easier but that's not
it it's it's i want to say more
meaningful but i feel like i use that
word way too much
but having people in my life it enhances
my life maybe that's the way so having
people in my life is an enhancement
so for me like i know that
uh if i am in a position where i don't
have a lot of people in my life
i will have to reach out and i will have
to foster some relationships
to enhance my life but here's the thing
is if you're going out of your way to
add value to other people's lives
there is no shame in asking for someone
else to add value
to your life i mean that's really how uh
you can do this in a way i mean maybe
there's always gonna be a pride thing
there
um i don't know what to say about the
pride except for get over it
like it's it's gonna be better if you
have people in your life
um if you if it's a guilty feeling like
you think you're taking advantage of
someone
well then that's a symptom of something
that maybe you should look at
so how can you ask someone for help
and not take advantage of them maybe
it's you know
hey i'll bring you over some groceries i
need some help watching my kids whatever
it is
you know find some way to add value to
other people's lives that way when you
ask
uh people to help you out you've already
kind of
laid the groundwork for uh for a
relationship that is is a give and take
it's not just a take
i like what you said about enhancing
because making that distinction between
yes our relationships will enhance our
life
but as soon as we need that help
or that relationship is no longer
enhancing it is hindering our life and
so making that distinction i think is
really important so
let me go back to ally's question here
when you're starting over from scratch
and you realize you can't do it alone
that's not true i would actually say
that you can
only do it alone and the people will
then
enhance or amplify augment
your life but they can't do it for you
so often people come to me and ryan
especially when we do our live event
which by the way they're
they're starting up again really soon
the minimalists.com
tour we're gonna do a bunch of live
events coming up heck yeah but people
will come up and they'll say
oh i wish i could just bring you guys
over my house and you could do
this for me and and ally i want you to
be careful
i know that's not what you're thinking
right now but that it can often
turn into that really quickly like oh
yeah i'm just going to get other people
to do
the work for me well yeah i could come
over and declutter your house for you
it's going to be re-cluttered really
quickly you know i think about the
people
who ask me for help in my life and
there are people who are working their
butt off
they are doing everything they can and
they reach out to me and they ask for
some help
maybe it's just some coaching maybe it's
for a loan or whatever it is i have no
problem
helping someone out when they are
putting forth the effort
someone who isn't putting forth the
effort and asks me for help
i'm still totally willing to help them
out but
there is a different feeling of and also
a different way i'm willing to help them
out
so if someone comes to me and asks me
for for money for example if a family
member or a friend
they're asking me for money um and i see
that they're not being very
responsible with their actions i'm less
likely to be like oh yeah here's some
money but if i have a
and i have had a family member who
working their butt off they just happen
to get into some type of pinch
hey can i borrow some money yeah no
problem they paid me back no problem
uh that other family member who isn't
really putting forth the effort i know
they're probably not going to pay me
back
and i try to live by the rule that you
do josh with you don't really lend
friends or family money you can you give
it to them yes you don't expect to get
it back
right but if you get it back great
because it ruins the relationship if all
of a sudden now i have an expectation or
i'm lording
over you and saying well yeah now and
even if i don't
even if i i i don't bring it up
constantly it will come up in my mind
like oh yeah ryan still owes me 50 bucks
or whatever right
and why would you let that ruin a
friendship and so
needing help is different from asking
for help i'll ask
friends for help all the time sean helps
out a lot jordan helps me out you help
me out
my wife helps me out my daughter never
helps out with anything
she helps drive you crazy yeah
and she complains the whole time while
she's doing it right
that's very helpful ella thank you no
but in all seriousness
i can ask for help but the moment that i
need that help i can't do it alone
well all of a sudden what that tells me
is
it's a disempowering narrative and i'm
outsourcing
my own abilities to other people no no
i'm able to do this on my own
it's i'm able to do it a little bit
easier
if other people help me out absolutely
yeah and this
man i just want to be careful because i
don't want to like guilt-trip someone
who's like yeah but
i do need help for x y or z like that's
that's fine like if you can truly look
in the mirror and say i need this help
like that's okay i don't know like worst
case scenario is like a paraplegic right
i need someone to help me out a better
whatever it is
like there are certain cases where uh
yeah it'd be better if you can do it on
your own but maybe you do need some help
when i broke my back
um you know i didn't necessarily need uh
mariah's
help no you didn't need it but it was
helpful but it was incredibly helpful
and it saved me from further damaging my
back because that's
that's just it is like when you break
your back you have to lay down and let
it heal you can't be walking around on
it and
you know picking stuff up so uh so i
needed her help in the sense that it
helped me
heal faster um but i totally agree with
what you're saying man like
95 of the time it's something that we
should be able to do on our own and when
we bring someone else's
someone else in it enhances the
situation
um but yeah again just like trying to
not guilt-trip anyone who like might
might be in a position where they're
like but no
i need my sister to watch my kids so i
can go to work i don't know man sure
every excuse is even the best excuse
just told me still an excuse yeah ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it is time for the lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round that's where ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maxims in the
show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place minimal maxims.com
oh by the way ryan that
number that you shared with folks
937-202-4654 they can text
that phone number with questions you and
i respond to that
text an emoji to us as well of the thing
that you've gotten rid of most recently
will respond back to as many people as
possible and we'll send you our
monday morning minimal maxim start your
week off with a little bit
of simplicity yeah i'll tell you what's
nice about that number two
is people have access to some things
first
that uh they normally wouldn't have
access to like just recently
um we were filming some trailers for
some stuff that were
we're working on with netflix nothing is
inked so i don't want to talk too much
about that but we needed extras
and we were able to send out a text and
say hey we need extras and if you
weren't on that list then you wouldn't
have received
that ask so yeah we had a dozen people
here locally
came out we had about 30 people who won
the show up we we
we selected about a dozen of them and
now they're gonna be part of this film
project we're working on
yeah anyway linda has a question for you
so linda writes in when you're starting
over with
nothing how do you live without
sentimental stuff in your life
well linda i can start with a pithy
answer and then we can try to unpack it
together here my pithy answer is this
minimalists don't focus on owning
nothing they focus on owning
only that which adds value to their
lives
and of course that's situational it's
personal
there's not the list of the 1000 things
that you should own or the things that
will serve a purpose in your life
because
that which adds value to my life may not
add value to yours and in fact even the
things that added value to my life
10 years ago 5 years ago 10 days ago
may not add value to my life today and
so it's
constantly questioning it's constantly
identifying
that which adds value so back to her
question here
when you're starting over with nothing
how do you live without
sentimental stuff in your life your
question
presupposes that you should
live without sentimental stuff in your
life but of course
there's no such thing as a sentimental
item it's only sentimental if we
if we impart sentiment onto it and so
a item that is sentimental for you linda
or an item that's sentimental for ryan
probably is not going to be sentimental
for me at all
it's because i'm not assigning that same
value to the item that you are and it's
not wrong that you're doing it
i just want to point out that if
everything is sentimental then
nothing really is sentimental if
everything is precious to you
then nothing is precious i could tell
you the thing i did with my mom's stuff
when i brought
some of it back i got rid of most of her
stuff i brought some of it back to ohio
when she was down in florida after she
passed away and
when she passed i realized i had to sort
through the sentimental items and she
had
thousands and thousands of things that
you could easily consider to be
oh yeah i should hold on to this just in
case and oh yeah i might want this
giant bed frame later this huge antique
dresser like they're nice things
they're certainly sentimental items i
would get some value from it too
as well right so it wasn't just like it
was it was a waste to hold on to it i
would even get some value from
but just because you might get some
value from a thing
is not a good reason to hold on to the
thing
and so what i realized that if i got rid
of most of the sentimental items and
kept a handful of sentimental items i
got far more value from those few
sentimental items i kept
than if i were to water them down with
10 000
sentimental trinkets you were talking
about these
these uh holding on to these things just
in case they become sentimental one day
there's something there with just in
case not just just in case items but
just in case sentimental items
that's the case i decide for this to be
sentimental one day yeah what do you got
for us
uh here's my pithy answer minimalists
focus
less on surviving and more on thriving
so what that means is if you are not
going to thrive
getting rid of all your sentimental
things then
don't get rid of all your sentimental
things what a great question how will
this help me thrive
yeah oh my god right that's because that
question illuminates so much because
a lot of these things we're holding on
to and they're actually we kind of dread
them
oh you know yeah but it's sentimental
but yeah but if you dread it
is it worth holding on to yeah but it
was important to my grandpa
right and that's wonderful that he found
so much value in it yeah
and he certainly wouldn't want it to
weigh you
down and so you can find a new home
just because you're not finding value
and it doesn't mean that someone else
won't find value in it
there are thousands of other homes that
could find value in that thing
and so in a weird way by holding on to
my mom's stuff i would have been selfish
if i just held on to those things for my
own sort of gratification or edification
yeah just sitting there in storage not
being used i mean you're doing
a disservice to your mother because
you're not even using the things that
she was using but
but then you're also doing that
disservice to someone else who might be
able to actually take that bring it into
their home and and
uh add value and ultimately i'm doing a
disservice to myself because
i dread it it's weighing on me the
psychological cost the mental cost the
emotional cost
of holding on to these things that i
know deep down in my heart
are just getting in the way yeah man
that's not a cost that i'm willing to
pay anymore and so if it's a sentimental
item that you get value from
wonderful i'm not saying you should live
your life without those things
those things enhance your life but the
other things
if they're getting in the way if they're
not helping you thrive as ryan says
well maybe it's time to let those things
go ryan we got a bunch more things to
talk about but first what do you got for
us here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out hi guys this is caroline
calling in from gaithersburg maryland
here are a few tips for all the folks
who are trying to be
minimal in their makeup consumption and
usage
for example i have a dark brown shade of
eye shadow
that i use as eyeshadow eyeliner and an
eyebrow filler
it doesn't smudge it's long lasting and
no one notices that my eye or
brow liners are actually eyeshadow you
can also use lipstick for your lips and
cheeks i smudge a small line across my
cheeks and rub it in full black for
blush
as for my skincare routine i have been
struggling with acne for over 10 years
after spending literally thousands of
dollars on forza face wash
products i decided enough was enough i
went to my kitchen
my kitchen for some face care solutions
i now wash my face with a warm water and
sea salt solution
which has cleared my acne up
tremendously
i also use a honey or aloe vera plant
mask
for 15 minutes every week to hydrate my
skin
just to make sure this is aloe vera
directly from a plant
not the gel you use when you're
sunburned totally different and the
ladder is filled with
a lot of lots of toxins and chemicals
depending on where you get it so please
don't put that on your face
lastly when i do break out i put one
drop of tea tree
essential oils onto a wet reusable
cotton ball
and rub it on the acne spot it serves as
a diy
acne treatment serum that is giving me
great results
so i hope this helps and shows you
examples of how minimal makeup
and skin care routines are possible and
effective
hi my name is lisa benson and i'm
calling from wall sam
mats i've been thinking a lot about
souvenirs when you go on a trip lately
or recently our ten-year-old niece came
up to visit us and she bought something
small for every family member
to show that she was thinking of them
when she was visiting and traveling
but i'm thinking of a different way that
you could show that to a friend or
family member without having to buy them
something which is
they give you something small to take
with you maybe it's a drawing or
a treasured object or whatever and
you take a picture of that object at
some landmark or a special place or
moment
and you share that photo with them so
it's like a piece of them was with you
on the trip
all right y'all we're going to begin
again this thursday on patreon
that's the maximum episode on the
minimalist private podcast you can check
it out patreon.com
the minimalist but first real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
or maybe two things going on in the life
of the minimalist
ryan and i have a new book coming out
i'll hold it up if you're watching on
youtube it's called
love people use things this isn't just
our
tagline is now a book but it's really
the north star by which
we've we've used to navigate our lives
over the last
decade or so right because unfortunately
in society we're taught unknowingly
to treat people as though they are
transactional
treat people like things and treat
things like people we love our things
and we use
people and man that is so broken
yeah and so what we've done is we've
written a book about this it's a
relationship book but it's about the
seven essential relationships in our
life
it comes out july 13th you can pre-order
it now but that's not the right here
right now
what i wanted to let you know is if you
pre-order the book you can attend our
event for free we're doing a virtual
tour stop
uh worldwide tour stop so head on over
to theminimalists.com
tour that day that the book comes out
july 13th we're gonna have special guest
irwin rafael mcmanus who's been on the
podcast before
but we're going to be talking to him
about how to heal
the essential relationships in your life
how to heal your relationship with
yourself
your relationship with money your
relationship with stuff
your relationship with people and so
much more
and all the details are over on our
website the minimalists.com
tour and that is our first tour stop in
over three years now
man i can't wait we had to cancel a tour
last year because there was some sort of
virus going around or something i don't
really remember
2020 is such a blur i blocked it out
myself
for added value this week speaking of
starting over
if i think of musicians who really
started over their career
it's andrew bell i feel like every album
he started over
yes like every single album it's it's
different
it's new and to get there it's like he
had to let go of everything
start over and then start working on his
new album what a beautiful way to put it
you had to let go of everything in order
to move on
you have to let go to move on and to
create something
beautiful which is exactly what he's
done and he has a new song out i don't
know if you've heard it it's my favorite
song of this year so far
it's just one song it's called my poor
heart
and i think it'll be from his upcoming
album oh wow but let's finish this
episode by listening to
my poor heart by andrew bell by the way
we have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like
what are 40 lessons you've learned
during your first 40 years on this
planet
if we're starting over what essentials
would you guys suggest
we keep what if i start over and realize
that was the wrong decision for me how
do i start over
as a minimalist with kids plus a million
more questions about starting over
and if you want to hear all that join us
on the minimalist private podcast this
week visit
patreon.com the minimalist to subscribe
and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app you'll get our weekly private
podcast we put out every thursday
we also have 50 different quarantine
conversations we recorded last year with
different people we just called up
people
recorded our phone calls 15 minutes 20
minutes 45 minutes
no matter how long it was we recorded
that conversation a bunch of meaningful
conversations we had last year
you can find all 50 of those over on
patreon also we did 30 of these videos
called the biggest failure videos and
you can find those
on patreon as well we talk to people
about some of their biggest failures and
the lessons they learn from those
failures plus
all of our archives hundreds of hours of
archives
more minimalism than you can chew
patreon.com slash the minimalist
you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast
at theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive any
new minimalist writings that we put out
there
for free and if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye